This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantantham. Several months ago, I noticed one of my colleagues taking breaks from work during the day. At first, I thought Max Nestrak was trying to build some exercise into his schedule. Good for him, I thought. But when I asked him about it, he confessed that he was stepping outside to smoke. We did a podcast episode about New York's resolutions and Max's resolution to quit smoking at the start of the year. It's 2016 and I have not smoked for two minutes.
这里是《隐藏大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。几个月前，我注意到我的一位同事在白天工作时会休息一会儿。起初，我认为马克斯·内斯特拉克是想在日程表里安排一些锻炼。我心想，这对他挺好的。但当我向他问起这事时，他坦白说他是出去抽烟了。我们做过一期关于新年愿望以及马克斯在年初戒烟决心的播客节目。现在是2016年，我已经两分钟没抽烟了。
Lots of you have written and phoned and emailed to ask how Max is doing and whether he's managed to stick to his resolution. Ah, I really want to cigarette. Yeah, about that. We'll get to it in a few minutes. Today we're going to talk about Max's story and three interventions I suggested to help him quit smoking. You can apply these ideas in your own life, whether that's giving up smoking or that three latte a day Starbucks habit. When Max decided to quit, he and I sat down to chat.
你们很多人写信、打电话、发邮件来问马克斯最近过得怎么样，他是否设法坚持了自己的戒烟决心。啊，我真的很想抽根烟。好吧，关于这个。我们几分钟后会聊到。今天我们要聊聊马克斯的故事，以及我为帮他戒烟而提出的三个干预措施。你可以将这些方法应用到你自己的生活中，无论是戒烟，还是戒掉每天三杯拿铁的星巴克习惯。当马克斯决定戒烟时，我和他坐下来聊了聊。
I asked him how he became a smoker and what cigarettes meant to him. So you told me that you started smoking when you were 14 or 15 years old. That seems shockingly young to me. It seems shockingly young to me too. I should say the first cigarette I actually smoked, I was 10 years old, it was Christmas and my aunt smoked so they would be on the back patio, shivering outside, and I'm like, I wonder what it's like to smoke a cigarette. My dad was like, sure, go ahead, join Aunt Doe and cousin Jenny and have a cigarette.
我问他是怎么成为烟民的，烟对他意味着什么。所以你告诉我，你是在14或15岁时开始抽烟的。这在我看来小得令人震惊。这在我看来也小得令人震惊。我得说，我真正抽的第一支烟时我10岁，那是圣诞节，我的阿姨们抽烟，所以她们会待在后院露台上，在外面瑟瑟发抖，然后我想，抽烟是什么感觉呢。我爸爸说，行，去吧，去陪多伊阿姨和珍妮表姐抽支烟吧。
And so I went outside and I had a cigarette, and I think his hope was that I would just vomit or just get so sick that I would never do it again because you never, you know, he never touched cigarettes. But, you know, I never did and I, you know, I didn't really have an effect. Um, I like you. I did like it. I did like it. I thought I liked it. I mean, I liked, you know, being there like with my family outside smoking.
于是我走到外面抽了一支烟，我想他的希望是我会直接呕吐，或者病得厉害到再也不碰这东西，因为你永远，你知道的，他从来不碰香烟。但是，你知道，我并没有吐，而且我，你知道，其实并没有什么不良反应。嗯，和你一样。我确实挺喜欢的。我确实挺喜欢的。我想我是喜欢的。我的意思是，我喜欢，你知道，和我的家人一起在外面抽烟的那种感觉。
I felt, um, kind of cool. And, and all the other cousins who are my age were kind of like peering out of the patio behind the glass door, the safety of the non-smoking kitchen, kitchen-knook, and just like what is Max doing? And there was in my coat huddling with the other ostracized family member smokers. What did your mom say about this? My mom I think rolled her eyes and she was like, I can't believe your dad said this was okay, but I hope you vomit too.
我感觉，嗯，挺酷的。所有和我同龄的表兄弟姐妹都在玻璃门后、非吸烟区的厨房隔间安全范围内向外张望，就像是在看马克斯在干什么。然后我和其他被排挤的吸烟家属成员挤在我的外套里。你妈妈对此怎么说？我妈妈当时好像翻了个白眼，心想，我真不敢相信你爸爸觉得这没问题，不过我也希望你吐。
But, as Max said, he didn't vomit. In fact, he liked smoking. A few years later, when he was a freshman in high school, he asked an older friend to buy him a pack of cigarettes. He began smoking regularly. I used to take the dog on walks, and that was like my smoke break. And so I think, you know, starting around age, you know, 14, that dog got so many walks a day,
但是，正如马克斯所说，他并没有吐。事实上，他很喜欢抽烟。几年后，当他是高中一年级新生时，他让一个大一点的朋友给他买了一包烟。他开始规律地抽烟。我以前经常带狗去散步，那就是我的吸烟时间。所以我想，你知道，从14岁左右开始，那只狗每天要散步好多次，
or like, it got increasingly more exercise as the years went on. So a scientist would say, there was an inverse relationship between the dog's health and your health. Correct. So I scientist would say there was an inverse relationship between the dog's health and your health. Correct. Yes, I think that's an app description. As he's gotten older, Max says he's become aware of the stigma around smoking. It didn't stop him, but it did make him think twice about telling friends and co-workers about his habit. I don't think it makes me cooler or more
或者随着时间的推移，运动量越来越大。所以科学家会说，狗的健康状况和你的健康状况之间存在负相关关系。没错。所以科学家会说，狗的健康状况和你的健康状况之间存在负相关关系。没错。是的，我认为这是一个贴切的描述。随着年龄的增长，马克斯说他开始意识到围绕吸烟的社会污名。这并没有阻止他，但确实让他三思而后行，是否要将这个习惯告诉朋友和同事。我不觉得这让我显得更酷或更
interesting, and generally I think when I first meet people I'm not afraid of being judged, but it's just something that's like Yeah, it's not something I just want to share right off the bat But if there's a social stigma to smoking there are also social benefits One thing Max and I discussed was the Smokers Club that forms outside of offices and libraries You see the same people congregating every day, chatting as they smoke. I mean, that's very profound, psychologically speaking. If you're constantly meeting people only at the times that you're
有趣，而且通常我刚认识别人时并不怕被评判，但这只是一种……对，这不是那种我想直接拿出来分享的事情。但如果吸烟存在社会污名，它也有社会好处。我和马克斯讨论过的一件事是办公室和图书馆外面形成的“烟民俱乐部”。你会看到同样的人每天聚在一起，边抽烟边聊天。我的意思是，从心理学角度来看，这非常深奥。如果你经常只在做你喜欢的事情时遇到人，那么这些人就会让你产生巴甫洛夫式的联想，将他们与你喜欢的事情联系起来。
doing something that you enjoy, those are people you're going to associate in a Pavlovian fashion with the thing that you enjoy. you're gonna be forming friendships with them, and now the friendships keep you in that world. Yeah, I think it's same with activities. I mean, the more you smoke, the better life gets, and I mean, smoking and television, smoking and eating breakfast, smoking and eating ice cream. But I think that's true with people that there is like,
你会和他们建立友谊，现在这些友谊会让你留在这个圈子里。是的，我觉得活动也是这样。我的意思是，你抽烟越多，生活就越美好，我是说，抽烟配电视，抽烟配早餐，抽烟配冰淇淋。但我认为人也是这样，有一种
this shared bond where you're out on the break. Right, the pleasure center is being activated and while you're talking, so you probably think the conversation is better. I think it's the same as when people go out to the bar to happy hour together and they have drinks. There's this bond that's formed that's, that just wouldn't be formed at work around the water cooler in a way. There are other clubs you get to join when you're a smoker,
共同的纽带，那就是你们一起出去透气。没错，快乐中枢被激活了，而且你们在交谈，所以你可能会觉得谈话更投机。我认为这就像人们一起去酒吧参加欢乐时光喝酒一样。这种纽带是自然形成的，是在工作中的饮水机旁绝对无法建立的。当你成为一个烟民时，你还可以加入其他俱乐部，
but of course, smokers like Max tend not to think of those clubs when they're smoking. With smoking, I associate myself with the film noir, the cigarette after dinner, the social smoking, but not the emphysema or lung cancer or oxygen mask part of the game, if you will. So that's the interesting thing, of course. And you know all the social science literature on this, which is that the pleasure and the social camaraderie and the friendships are real and immediate, and the potential costs are delayed and distant. And there's just six warehouses filled with psych studies that basically
但当然，像马克斯这样的烟民在抽烟时往往不会去想那些俱乐部。对于抽烟，我会联想到黑色电影、饭后一支烟、社交吸烟，而不是肺气肿、肺癌或吸氧面具这些代价，如果你懂我的意思的话。所以这很有趣，当然。你知道所有关于这方面的社会科学文献，那就是快乐、社会情谊和友谊是真实且即时的，而潜在的代价则是延迟且遥远的。有整整六个仓库装满了心理学研究，基本上
show that when you set up the incentives this way so that the short term incentives are positive and gratifying and the long term incentives are horrible, people will ignore the long term and focus on the short term. Yeah, I think there's never a good day to quit smoking, right? You know, there's the part of yourself that wants to wake up at six o'clock in the morning. And so you set the alarm clock. The you at six o'clock in the morning presses the snooze button 20 times until it's eight o'clock and then you're rushing to work and you're late. And you know, there's the part of myself at night who says, okay, tomorrow
表明，当你这样设定激励机制，使短期激励是积极且令人满足的，而长期激励是可怕的时候，人们就会忽视长期，只关注短期。是的，我觉得戒烟永远没有一个好日子，对吧？你知道，你内心的一部分想在早上六点醒来。于是你定了个闹钟。早上六点醒来的你把贪睡按钮按了20次，直到八点，然后你匆忙赶去上班，还迟到了。你知道，我内心深处在晚上时会说，好吧，明天
I'm going to stop smoking. And then you wake up and you have one and then you're like, well, if I had one I'm not going to go the rest of the day without without smoking and so it's easy to weigh the long-term benefits of smoking when you're not craving a cigarette. An old smoker's joke says quitting is easy. Adonate lots of times. Knowing that most people who quit go back to smoking, I suggested that Max do three things to help him stick to his resolution. All were ideas drawn from social science research. First, I asked him to put the money he was spending on smoking, about six bucks a day,
我要戒烟。然后你醒来抽了一支，接着你就会想，好吧，既然已经抽了一支，那我今天剩下的时间也戒不了烟了，所以在你并不渴望抽烟时，很容易去权衡吸烟的长期好处。一个老烟民的笑话是，戒烟太容易了。我已经戒过好多次了。深知大多数戒烟的人最后都会复吸，我建议马克斯做三件事来帮助他坚持决心。这些都是汲取自社会科学研究的想法。首先，我让他把花在抽烟上的钱——大约一天六美元——存入一个储蓄账户。
into a savings account. If he succeeded in quitting at the end of the year, he would be able to go on a nice vacation. But if he started smoking, he would have to donate the money to an organization he did test. Now, I'm not going to identify it, but let's just say Max picked an organization that does a lot of lobbying in Washington. Second, I asked him to reach out to a bunch of friends and ask them to be there for him when he needed support. And finally, I asked him to reach out to a bunch of friends and ask them to be there for him when he needed support. And finally, I asked him to record a public service announcement about why young people should never start smoking.
如果他在年底成功戒烟，他就能去度个美好的假。但如果他复吸了，他就必须把这笔钱捐给他讨厌的机构。现在，我不打算指名道姓，但我们只能说马克斯挑选了一个在华盛顿有很多游说活动的机构。其次，我让他联系一群朋友，请他们在需要支持时给予陪伴。最后，我让他录制了一则公益广告，讲述为什么年轻人永远不应该开始抽烟。
The idea is that when you publicly declare you're against smoking, it makes it hard to start smoking again. It produces cognitive dissonance, makes you feel like a hypocrite. We aired Max's public service announcement in January. Here's an excerpt. If you don't smoke, here's what you should know. When your smoker life is lived around cigarettes. You'll be laughing with friends at dinner or totally engrossed in a good book, and something will tug at you. And as much as you want to stay in this moment, you'll
这个想法是，当你公开宣布自己反对吸烟时，你就很难再开始抽烟了。这会产生认知失调，让你觉得自己像个伪君子。我们在1月播出了马克斯的公益广告。以下是一个片段。如果你不抽烟，这里有件事你应该知道。当你的烟民生活围绕着香烟展开时。你会和朋友在晚餐时开怀大笑，或者完全沉浸在一本好书中，而有些东西会拉扯你。不管你多么想留在这一刻，你都会
be thinking about a cigarette. So you'll get up, walk outside, and light up. And it will feel really good. But you'll wish you were back outside, and light up. And it will feel really good. But you'll wish you were back inside, and you'll be so tired of training off these moments for a smoke. If you don't smoke, you should know that smoking makes a prison out of perfectly normal situations. Long flights, concerts, class, anything that lasts longer than a couple of hours. These are your enemies as a smoker. And anytime you go on a date or to a job interview or to your grandparents house, it will be accompanied by a pang of worry. You'll wash your hands and pull your shirt to your nose, and I hope they can't smell
想着一支烟。所以你会起身，走到外面，点燃它。感觉会真的很好。但你会希望自己当时是在里面，而且你会厌倦用这些时刻去换取抽烟。如果你不抽烟，你应该知道吸烟会把完全正常的情况变成监狱。漫长的航班、音乐会、课堂，任何持续时间超过几个小时的事情。作为烟民，这些都是你的敌人。而任何时候你去约会、去面试或去祖父母家，都会伴随着一丝担忧。你会洗手，把衬衫拉到鼻子前，希望他们闻不到
smoke. We also asked something from all of you. We asked that you call in with your own stories about how you managed to quit smoking. We were absolutely overwhelmed and moved by your responses. So many of you wrote and called with words of wisdom and encouragement. the resolutions podcast. And I was actually on the way home from my dad having surgery on his lungs for lung cancer. So I just wanted to wish Max good luck. And hopefully he's able to quit.
烟味。我们也向你们所有人提出了一个请求。我们请你们打电话分享你们自己成功戒烟的故事。你们的回复让我们感到无比震撼和感动。你们中的许多人写信和打电话表达了智慧之言和鼓励。 resolutions播客。当时我实际上正坐在爸爸做肺癌肺部手术回家的路上。所以我只是想祝马克斯好运。希望他能戒烟成功。
And this isn't him in 50 years. My dad is 74, so. There's no need to badmouth the old self, but best to nurture the new direction with as many creative ways as you can come up with. I have no doubt you will succeed. It's been 28 years since the day I quit. The thing that really helped me was not to focus on the whole project but on the steps.
这不会是50年后的他。我爸爸74岁了，所以。没有必要说旧自己的坏话，最好是用你能想到的各种创造性方式来孕育新的方向。我毫不怀疑你会成功。自我戒烟那天起已经过去28年了。真正帮到我的不是专注于整个宏大计划，而是专注于每一个步骤。
For instance, I kept repeating to me every time I had the urge of going out and smoking the cigarette. Well, this one you're not going to smoke it. So, I mean, I just concentrate my attention and my power on the single cigarette that I was craving. And that way, cigarette by cigarette, I successfully quit it. I threw out my cigarettes and in that moment I decided that not only was I going to quit smoking, but that I would become a non-smoker right then. And from then on, every time I would want a cigarette, I would ask myself why in the world a non-smoker would want to cigarette. Go to the places where you usually buy cigarettes and introduce yourself to the person behind
例如，每次我有冲动想出去抽烟时，我都会不断对自己重复。好吧，这一支你是不抽的。所以，我的意思是，我将注意力和意志力集中在我渴望的那支单独的烟上。通过这种方式，一支烟接着一支烟，我成功地戒掉了。我扔掉了香烟，在那一刻我决定，我不但要戒烟，而且我从那一刻起就要成为一个不抽烟的人。从那时起，每当我想抽烟时，我都会问自己，一个不吸烟的人为什么会在世界上想抽烟呢。去你平时买烟的地方，向柜台后面的人做个自我介绍，
the counter and just let them know that you're trying to stop smoking. You don't have to tell them not to sell you cigarettes or anything like that, but just say to them that you're trying to stop smoking. It's going to be really hard for you to then go back there and buy cigarettes. We're gonna take a break now. When we come back, we're gonna hear from Max. He kept an audio diary as he went along to document his triumphs and setbacks. It's like this mental obsession, so you're kind of like, oh, should I have a granola bar, no one has cigarette. Should I go for a walk, no, I won't have a cigarette.
让他们知道你在尝试戒烟。你不需要告诉他们不要卖烟给你或类似的话，只需对他们说你在尝试戒烟。之后你很难再厚着脸皮回去买烟了。我们现在要休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将听到马克斯的声音。他在戒烟过程中写了一份音频日记，记录他的成功与挫折。这就像是一种精神强迫症，所以你有点像，哦，我要不要吃燕麦棒，不，我要抽烟。我要不要去散步，不，我要抽烟。
Stay with us. Quitting smoking is kind of like a really bad breakup. At first, I'm okay. I feel relieved. Happy even, that I finally did it. This isn't so bad. I go to bed that night looking forward to waking up the next day as a new person. Tomorrow is January 1st, 2016.
请继续收听。戒烟有点像经历一场非常糟糕的分手。起初，我很好。我感到解脱。甚至很高兴，我终于做到了。这并不是那么糟。那天晚上我上床睡觉，期待着第二天醒来时成为一个崭新的人。明天是2016年1月1日。
It's going to be the first day of the rest of my so much better life. Of course, the first thing I think about when I wake up is a cigarette. I plan to go downstairs and pour myself a cup of coffee, bundle up in my winter coat, and have the first cigarette of the day, which is, as any smoker will tell you, the best cigarette of the day. Then I remember what I'd done. Said I would quit smoking. And I do not stop remembering it. I started keeping an audio diary. Here's a clip. It's just, it's like this mental obsession. So you're kind of like, oh, should I have a granola
这将是我好得多的余生的第一天。当然，我醒来后想到的第一件事就是香烟。我计划下楼给自己倒杯咖啡，裹上冬衣，抽一天中的第一支烟，正如任何烟民都会告诉你的那样，这是这一天中最好的一支烟。然后我想起了我做过的事。我说过我要戒烟。而且我一直在提醒自己这一点。我开始写音频日记。这里有一个剪辑。这简直，这就像是一种精神强迫症。所以你有点像，哦，我要不要吃燕麦
bar? No, I want to have a cigarette. Should I go for a walk? No, I want to have a cigarette. Should I watch movie? No, I want to have a cigarette. So that's, it's just like the obsession, it's all you want, and that's all you can think about. I think back to the early days of the romance. When I would get lightheaded, tingling my fingers, and just feel giddy. I started smoking around the time I realized I was gay.
棒？不，我想抽烟。我要不要去散步？不，我想抽烟。我要不要看电影？不，我想抽烟。所以这就是，这就像是强迫症，这就是你想要的全部，这也是你唯一能想到的事情。我回想起恋爱的早期阶段。当我感到头晕目眩、手指发麻、甚至飘飘然的时候。我大约在我意识到自己是同性恋的时候开始抽烟。
I went to high school in suburban Colorado with a champion football team, and well, by the time I started smoking at 14, I needed it. Sometimes I would inhale as much as I could, close my eyes, and just let my head buzz while I held in the smoke. The withdrawal feels like just the opposite. I'm sad and frustrated. My headaches, my muscles tighten up, my thoughts are foggy. I'm acutely aware that there's suffering in the world. When you're having a craving, you just, you don't think that you're ever gonna feel differently, or half felt differently. I try to embrace it.
我在科罗拉多州郊区的一所高中上学，那里有一支冠军橄榄球队，好吧，当我14岁开始抽烟时，我需要它。有时我会尽可能深地吸一口，闭上眼睛，在憋着烟的同时让脑袋嗡嗡作响。戒断反应感觉恰恰相反。我很悲伤和沮丧。我头痛，肌肉紧绷，思绪模糊。我敏锐地意识到世界上存在痛苦。当你烟瘾犯的时候，你就是，你不会觉得你的感觉会有所不同，或者曾经有过不同的感觉。我试着去接受它。
A craving comes and I just lean into it. You have to love the burn almost. You know what I mean? Like you, it sucks, it hurts, and you just kind of lean into it. And you're like, yeah, this is what quitting feels like. And yeah, so I'm loving the burn right now. Loving hating the burn right now. I'm chewing sugar-free gum and drinking salsa water.
烟瘾来了，我只是顺应它。你几乎必须要热爱这种灼烧感。你知道我的意思吗？就像你，这很糟糕，这很痛，你只是顺应它。你会觉得，是的，这就是戒烟的感觉。所以是的，我现在很享受这种灼烧感。现在又爱又恨这种灼烧感。我在嚼无糖口香糖，喝苏打水。
These are my sad romance song and cinnamon bun equivalents. I bask in the pain and let my mind do what it wants to do. Think about how much it sucks to not have a cigarette. Then I think about something I heard about Buffalo. That when Buffalo see a storm coming they walk towards it rather than away from it because they know they'll get through it faster. I am the Buffalo. It's like three minutes away from being 40 hours so it's at the end of day two. There were some dark moments today. I don't know if I can take another day of this.
这些是我悲伤的情歌和肉桂卷的替代品。我沉浸在痛苦中，让我的大脑做它想做的事。想想没有烟抽有多糟。然后我想起我听说过关于野牛的一件事。当野牛看到风暴来临时，它们会迎着风暴走，而不是背对着它，因为它们知道这样能更快地穿过风暴。我就是那头野牛。距离40小时还有大约三分钟，所以这是第二天结束的时候。今天有一些黑暗的时刻。我不知道我是否能再忍受这样的一天。
I think about the money I've saved on cigarettes that I'd have to donate to that horrible organization if I smoked. It's actually only $13. I think if I'm going to relapse, I should do it now while they're so little at stake. Then I think about having to say I failed on this podcast. I Google quitting smoking timeline. After 20 minutes, your blood pressure and heart rate will return to normal. After 12 hours, blood oxygen level has increased to normal. 48 hours, damaged nerve endings start to regrow and anger and irritability have peaked. 72 hours, entire body is free of nicotine, number of cravings have peaked, lung function is improving. I make it today 3, I go for a run, and I'm surprised at how much my lungs have already recovered.
我想到了我省下的烟钱，如果我抽烟了，我就得把这些钱捐给那个可怕的机构。其实只有13美元。我想如果我要复吸，我应该现在就复吸，趁现在损失还这么小。然后我想到了我必须在这个播客上承认我失败了。我在谷歌上搜索戒烟时间表。20分钟后，你的血压和心率会恢复正常。12小时后，血液中的氧气水平增加到正常水平。48小时，受损的神经末梢开始重新生长，愤怒和易怒达到顶峰。72小时，体内完全没有尼古丁，烟瘾发作次数达到顶峰，肺功能正在改善。我撑到了第3天，我去跑步了，我惊讶于我的肺部已经恢复了那么多。
The cravings come less frequently, just like the quitting smoking websites promise they will. I'm nearly 3 weeks in a quitting smoking now. It's day 20 and the most amazing thing happens. I woke up and I drank a glass of orange juice. I took a shower, I got dressed, I packed my bag for work and you know as about to head out, I realized that I hadn't thought about a cigarette the entire morning. I'd literally gone through my entire routine without one thinking about a cigarette, and of course, then I was thinking about a cigarette.
烟瘾发作的频率降低了，正如那些戒烟网站承诺的那样。现在我戒烟快三周了。今天是第20天，发生了一件最神奇的事。我醒来喝了一杯橙汁。我洗了个澡，穿好衣服，收拾好上班的包，你知道正准备出门时，我意识到整个早上我都没有想过一支烟。我字面意义上完成了整个日常流程却没有想过烟，当然，接着我就开始想烟了。
But it was incredible because for me, by that time, I would have already had a cigarette and would have been planning to have my next one right as I walked out the door. I've made it this far before. I quit for about six months when I was 18 and last year I quit for 10 months so this isn't even the longest I've gone without smoking. I Google how many people successfully quit smoking. It says 90% of smokers who try to quit relapse in the first year. The last time I quit I relapse on a black and mild, one of those 60 cents of guards they sell at gas stations. I think I've only smoked one other black and mild, one of those 60 cents a gars they sell at gas stations.
但这太不可思议了，因为对我来说，到那个时候，我本来已经抽过一支烟，并正计划着一出门就抽下一根。我以前也曾坚持到过这一步。我18岁时戒过大约六个月，去年我又戒了10个月，所以这甚至不是我坚持最久的一次不吸烟记录。我在谷歌上搜索有多少人成功戒烟。上面说90%尝试戒烟的烟民在第一年都会复吸。上一次我戒烟时，我因为“黑与美”（Black & Mild，一种雪茄品牌）而复吸，就是加油站卖的那种60美分的雪茄。我想我一生中只抽过另一支“黑与美”，
I think I've only smoked one other black and mild in my life, when I was 16 at a house party. I bought it because they're strong, and you can buy one at a time. I thought if I could just have one really strong cigarette, it'd be enough to last me the rest of my life. The next day, I bought a pack of camel lights. This time, I noticed a way from black and miles. It's been about a month since I quit smoking, and I'm walking home from work. It's cold, but sunny, I'm happy. I see a guy about my age step out of his office and start walking in front of me. He reaches into his coat pocket and puts a cigarette
那是我16岁在一个派对上。我买它是因为它很劲大，而且可以单支买。我以为只要抽一支真的很浓的烟，就足够维持我余生了。第二天，我买了一包骆驼淡味烟。这一次，我注意到自己远离了“黑与美”。我戒烟大约一个月了，正走在下班回家的路上。天气很冷，但阳光明媚，我很开心。我看到一个跟我差不多大的男人从他的办公室走出来，开始走在我前面。他把手伸进外套口袋，把一支烟送到
to his mouth. Then he reaches into his other pocket, and I see him do that familiar pause to light up before he starts walking again. The smoke drifts back to me, and I'm just jealous that he's not doing a radio story about quitting smoking. He reminds me of how much I miss the ritual of the afterwork cigarette.
嘴里。然后他把手伸进另一个口袋，我看到他做了那个熟悉的停顿，点燃香烟，然后才继续往前走。烟味飘回到我身边，我只是嫉妒他不用做一档关于戒烟的广播节目。他让我想起了我是多么怀念下班后抽烟的那个仪式感。
I've had a bunch of cravings like this. So I've had to call my friend Larry Hanson and Minneapolis. He's a former smoker and one of the support people or shunkers suggested I line up before quitting. It's like, I don't know. I wish I could smoke without any of the consequences. But that's magical thinking, Max. Don't even go there. Yeah, don't even go there. I mean, that's foolish. We can't do it. It's not in the stars for us. I couldn't light up a cigarette and just say, oh, I'll have a cigarette and I won't have another one for six months or something like that. It wouldn't work that way for me, you know, I'm sure.
我经历过很多次这样的烟瘾。所以我不得不打电话给明尼苏达州的 ছাড়友拉里·汉森（Larry Hanson）。他是一个前烟民，也是尚卡尔建议我在戒烟前找好的支持人员之一。这就像，我不知道。我希望我能在没有任何后果的情况下抽烟。但这只是魔法般的思维，马克斯。别想那些。是的，别想那些。我的意思是，那是愚蠢的。我们做不到。这不是我们的宿命。我无法点燃一支烟然后说，哦，我就抽这一根，接下来的六个月我再也不抽了或者类似的话。对我来说事情不会那样发展，你知道的，我确信。
And I don't want to even experiment and you know, say, oh, would that really happen? You know, no, I don't care. I'm not gonna try. I asked Larry if it was hard for him to quit. You know, I told you how I had tried to quit and I would go by cigarettes and then smoke one and then flush them down the toilet. And then I tried the various things.
而且我甚至不想去尝试，然后说，哦，真的会那样发生吗？不，我不在乎。我不会去尝试。我问拉里戒烟对她来说是不是很难。你知道的，我跟你说过我是怎么尝试戒烟的，我会去买烟，然后抽一支，接着把剩下的冲进马桶。然后我尝试了各种方法。
They tried tapering off and then I tried going to smoke low, whatever those, you know, they were supposed to be like, I don't know, diet cigarettes or something like that. Then I asked him what I've been most scared to ask him. Does he still miss it? Well, I mean, I feel great now. I mean, I'm 72 years old and I haven't smoked for more than 30 years. And I know, if I were still smoking now, it would, well, I just, I can't imagine it. But to answer your question, did, do I miss it?
他们尝试过逐渐减量，然后我尝试去抽淡烟，或者不管那些被认为是，我不知道，减肥烟还是类似的东西。然后我问了他我一直最害怕问他的问题。他现在还怀念吗？好吧，我的意思是，我现在感觉很好。我的意思是，我已经72岁了，而且有30多年没抽烟了。我知道，如果我现在还在抽烟，那会……好吧，我简直无法想象。但为了回答你的问题，我怀念吗？
I don't really, you know? And you know, when I was in Vienna back in November, they still allow smoking in some cafes there. As soon as you walked in the door of the place, it wreaked of smoke. And it's just not a pleasant kind of experience. And maybe that was a line that I crossed when I used to get a whiff of cigarette smoke and there would be this paying of remorse.
其实没有，你知道吗？你知道，去年11月我在维也纳时，那里的一些咖啡馆仍然允许吸烟。你一走进那个地方的门，里面就弥漫着烟味。那根本不是一种愉快的体验。也许那是我跨过的一条界限，以前当我闻到一丝烟味时，会产生一丝懊悔。
Or, ooh, that smells good. I wish I could have a cigarette right now. And then I've passed that point now and I you know I just go oh what's that smell it stinks you know yeah I have not reached that point yet when I smell cigarette it still smells pretty good to me but I'm so grateful I don't have to smoke anymore every time I run I'm grateful I don't smoke I'm grateful I don't have to get up and leave my desk all the time I'm grateful I don't need a cigarette when I feel stressed or or sad, or happy.
或者，哦，那闻起来真香。我希望现在能抽根烟。而我现在已经过了那个阶段，你知道的，我只会想，那是什么味道？真臭，你知道的，是的，我还没达到那个阶段，当我闻到烟味时，对我来说闻起来仍然挺香的，但我太感激自己不用再抽烟了。每次跑步我都感激自己不抽烟，我感激自己不用总是起身离开办公桌，我感激自己在感到压力、悲伤或快乐时不再需要一根烟。
I used to smoke every couple hours, every hour on the weekends. Last week, I looked up at the clock and couldn't believe how late it was. That rarely happened to me as a smoker, but it happens to me all the time now. It wasn't anything unusual, I cooked dinner with my roommate, we played a few games of cribbage, and we were laughing about something or other as I ate my nightly bowl of cereal. Before, each of these moments were bookended by a cigarette. Now, I'm just here, present. It's been 186 days without a cigarette, but I'm by no means out of the woods. I thought I'd be able to say, I quit cigarette, but I'm by no means out of the woods.
我以前每隔几小时就要抽一根，周末甚至每小时一根。上周，我抬头看了一眼时钟，简直不敢相信已经这么晚了。这在我抽烟时很少发生，但现在却时常发生。那没什么特别的，我和室友一起做了晚饭，玩了几局克里比奇牌，当我吃着每晚的麦片粥时，我们为某些事情开怀大笑。以前，这些时刻的头尾都有香烟相伴。现在，我就在这里，活在当下。我已经186天没抽烟了，但我绝没有脱离危险期。我以为我可以说，我戒了烟，但我绝没有脱离危险期。
I thought I'd be able to say, I quit smoking, but I realize it's not something I get to say yet. I just get to say, I'm not smoking today. But I think one day I'll get to the point where I can go to a beautiful place like Vienna full of outdoor cafes with strong espresso and ash trays at every table. And think, those cigarettes, they just stink. As I listen to Max, I realized one really hard thing about giving up smoking is that you don't get to declare victory. You don't get to say, okay, I'm done. The victory is always provisional. But recently, I was speaking with Tom Frieden, who heads the Centers for Disease Control
我以为我可以说，我戒烟了，但我意识到这不是我现在能说的话。我只能说，我今天没有抽烟。但我认为总有一天我会达到这样一个境界：我可以去一个像维也纳这样美丽的地方，那里到处都是露天咖啡馆，有浓郁的意式浓缩咖啡，每张桌子上都有烟灰缸。然后心想，那些烟，真臭。听着马克斯的话，我意识到戒烟真正困难的一点在于，你不能宣布胜利。你不能说，好吧，我完成了。胜利总是暂时的。但最近，我在与疾病控制与预防中心（CDC）负责人汤姆·弗里登（Tom Frieden）交谈时，
and Prevention, the CDC. I told him about Max. Tom told me that getting to 6 months is huge. Turns out, every day you stay off smoking makes it less likely you'll ever go back. The longer you quit, the longer you quit. Max had one big source of inspiration these last six months that he isn't going to have going forward. That's you.
我跟他聊起了马克斯。汤姆告诉我，坚持到6个月是一个巨大的里程碑。事实证明，你远离吸烟的每一天，都会让未来复吸的可能性变得更小。你戒烟的时间越长，你就越能保持下去。在过去的这六个月里，马克斯有一个巨大的灵感来源，而这个来源以后不会有了。那就是你们。
Max knew we were going to put together this podcast six months after he stopped smoking and he knew lots of you were waiting for it. He didn't want to tell you he'd failed. On the plus side, he's now put away more than a thousand dollars in that savings account, and he's going to donate all that money to that evil organization if he goes back to smoking. They're going to do terrible things with the money max, awful things. Don't let them do it. If you want to help Max, follow him on Twitter at Max Nestrak. He's agreed that if he ever goes back to smoking,
马克斯知道我们会在他戒烟六个月后制作这档播客，他也知道你们很多人都在等待。他不想告诉你们他失败了。从好的方面来看，他现在已经在储蓄账户里存了一千多美元，如果他复吸，他将把所有的钱捐给那个邪恶的机构。他们会用这些钱做出可怕的事情，马克斯，可怕的事情。别让他们这么做。如果你想帮助马克斯，请在Twitter上关注他@Max Nestrak。他已经同意，如果他有朝一日复吸，
he'll announce it the same day publicly on Twitter. I know you'll have his back. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Maggie Pennman and Max Nestrak. It was edited by Michael May and Jenny Schmitt. Our staff also includes Karamagar Galasin and Chris Benderf. You can find us on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram and listen to my stories on your local public radio station. If you liked this episode, please consider giving us a review on iTunes or any other podcast platform. It will help other people find the show.
他会在当天在Twitter上公开宣布。我知道你们会支持他的。本期《隐藏大脑》由玛吉·佩恩曼（Maggie Pennman）和马克斯·内斯特拉克（Max Nestrak）制作。迈克尔·梅（Michael May）和珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmitt）参与了编辑。我们的工作人员还包括卡拉马加·加拉辛（Karamagar Galasin）和克里斯·本德夫（Chris Benderf）。你可以在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上找到我们，并在你当地的公共广播电台收听我的故事。如果你喜欢这期节目，请考虑在iTunes或任何其他播客平台上给我们写个好评。这会帮助其他人找到这个节目。
I'm Shankar Vedanthan and this is NPR. I'm Shankar Vedantin and this is MPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这是NPR。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这是NPR。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。